Hey guys, Pete here. This will be my Game
of Thrones season 8 episode 1 recap and
review. The long wait has finally ended
and we've all been able to watch the
episode by now of course if you haven't
seen it this video will be spoilery go
watch it and then come back afterwards.
I'm gonna go through the entire episode
looking at the big points and things but
some of my personal thoughts and initial
reactions were that it was pretty solid
certainly not perfect but season openers
are generally table setting and Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 1 is in that
tradition I have real fears about the
speed and pacing of developments in the
story since there's only six episodes
total and season 8 and it did move
pretty fast there were a lot of cool
callbacks though the reunions were
mostly good and other than it leaking
early on Direct TV streaming service it
went down in a way that matched my
expectations I was totally with Cersei
about the golden company not bringing
the elephants and even though the Theon
Yara thing and the Jon riding the dragon
thing we're a bit underwhelming compared
to how I hope they might have played out
I think that we can mostly chalk that
kind of stuff up to this being the first
episode it's no secret the plot is all
pointing to the battle in the third
episode so one thing we can't argue
about is that the table is set for that
to happen hopefully there isn't much
that needs to be rushed and let's just
jump into this recap the first thing we
see is the new opening credits scene we
don't get a cold open this time this was
already out there because the actress
who plays Melisandre Carice van Houten
posted it to her Instagram stories
during the red carpet premiere it looks
cool what's a bit unfamiliar since they
don't go to as many places anymore but
we see the wall broken down snow moving
through the north to the last hearth
where it stops for now and then we just
see Winterfell and King's Landing
we do go through the locations now
rather than just getting an aerial view
though the crypts look cool in
Winterfell and we see the Scorpion in
the lower levels of the red keep we're
Balerion
the black dread skull is. the astrolabe
is probably my favorite part of it how
they added new events to that it seems
good that they can kind of update this
with each episode so that's a good job
done on that even though we already knew
that the first scene is gonna be a big
callback to Robert's arrival I think
this is actually one of the best
sequences in the entire episode when I
watched it the first time to me it had
like a feature film kind of feeling you
know what I mean everything was put
together really well here watching arias
face as the different characters from
her past go by and just the whole idea
in general that in episode 1 this was
aria and bran that were really excited
and now we have this new little kid
who's in stark contrast of everyone else
that's attending this event the people
in the crowd don't look excited that
this is all going down but the kid is
really excited to see this Dragon Queen
and see the Dragons and I really don't
have any problems with this sequence at
all I think that it was really it well
executed and did what it had to do show
that the North is not going to be
welcoming to what's going to go down in
the beginning as they enter of the yard
at Winterfell we see bran and John
reunite thought it was interesting that
bran seemed to show some affection here
I think we're gonna see him battle with
losing himself into being the three-eyed
Raven throughout this season and I've
heard Isaac Hempstead Wright mentioned
in interviews that he's more bran when
he's around his family and around
familiar things we see a bit of a
callback to when John left Winterfell
he gave Brandon a kiss on the head and
when he returns he gives bran a kiss on
the head inside the Great Hall of
Winterfell things start to materialize
the way that you think they might do
Lyanna Mormont is the voice for everyone
and saying like hey wait a minute we
named you the king in the north and you
just went down south and kneeled Sansa
pulls their card a bit by saying that
how they're gonna feed everyone which is
pretty reasonable and I think here
what's interesting is that Lyanna
Mormont whether you like the character
or not she makes a valid
point same thing with Sansa it's a valid
point but John and Daenerys are
motivated by actually seeing the night
king and his army so I think this is
actually pretty normal I think the what
we see here you know we see them send a
number back north and we see that
there's some tension but there should be
it will take time for some people to
absorb the threat that's actually
heading their direction poor Ned number
has a part to play in all of that of
course so it's fitting that they send
them away during the sequence
Sahn Centurion reunion was something I
wasn't sure how that would go they
didn't exactly warm up to each other
right here if we were thinking that
Tyrion would have an ally in Sansa it's
not clear that that happened at least
not in their reunion I like the nod to
the purple wedding and King Joffrey's
death how she said that there it had its
moments but it mirrored the hound and
arias reunion in a way that you know
they were brought together and became
allies but under kind of strained
circumstances all the way around for
both people involved John and Arya
coming back together it was good I think
it's fitting that she underlines how
that's important the family is important
how she stands up for Sansa a bit I
thought it was nice that she shows some
emotion because she doesn't really do
that anymore and we see her look like
her old self in glimpses during this
conversation we realized John has no
idea what she's been through and there's
no way for her to tell him all about
that at this point but I think the big
takeaway here is that family is
important and that's gonna come into
play more during the rest of the season
we take a trip down to the south and we
see King's Landing and I had an idea
that this might happen of course this is
all based on the fact that everyone
thought that Cersei was gonna lose her
baby I thought there may be an outside
chance that she would bed Joran because
of that fact so you know this kind of
reinforces that idea I don't know if
that's 100% what's going on if she's
trying to get pregnant again so she can
pass it off because there's a lot of
different things going on here on the
one hand she's giving the crossbow that
Tyrion used to kill Tywin
Braun trying to get him in her service
to kill those two that's probably
related to her fear of Maggie the frog
and the younger brother idea politically
that makes sense because Bronn isn't
really the kind of guy you want to have
around if they do come back so sending
him away makes sense either way it's
kind of like well if he kills him that's
good but at least he's not here either
way as mentioned I did love the exchange
with Harry Strickland when she brings up
the elephants it's classically in Headey
and I think that we need these kind of
moments before everything gets going
show y'all run is still underwhelming
and he's just here to play this role I
was sorta on the edge of my seat when it
went in and we saw you are sitting there
I was wondering if she was gonna have a
tongue or not and when she'd spoke it
was cool then they kind of gave a nod to
the books where he talks about having a
crew of mutes but the Theon rescuing her
seemed really rushed for me there was
just a feeling like they had to get this
done so they could get Theon back to
Winterfell that's really what I'm hoping
is going to pay off into being something
like we can get over this whole idea
because there's something important for
Theon to do in the north but overall the
King's Landing stuff was really just
there to fill us in I'm not sure Bronn
would actually follow through I think
we're supposed to wonder about that one
way or the other he paints himself as a
mercenary that will do anything for the
right price but we also know that he's
been close with Jaime and Tyrion so will
he really kill him I don't know back at
Winterfell we see Davos tyrion and varys
speaking and they're essentially talking
about the problems that are in front of
Daenerys as far as winning over the
north it escalates to talking about a
marriage proposal this is a good idea of
course it makes sense from all angles as
far as the interested parties are
concerned I think what stands out about
these three is they sort of don't have a
place in the actual battle so they have
to have something to do and I think you
kind of see it on their face like Varys
looks completely like a fish out of
water so that's something to think about
at this point the moment we
all been waiting for seeing Jon Snow
ride a dragon happens and for me it
didn't really work I mentioned that
earlier it just happened so simply and
it was comical and yeah it was fun to
watch but it wasn't what I wanted it to
be and you know depending on your own
expectations is probably how you felt
about it as well
for all the time that was spent thinking
about whether Jon could ride a dragon
or how he would ride a dragon I don't
think anyone ever came up with the idea
that it would be like this but we get to
see a moment with them together it's a
callback to John's time with Ygritte the
waterfall and all that is very
impressive looking and I guess it's
funny the way that drogon is looking at
the two but you know it just didn't
really work for me I don't know it's I
don't really need to talk about it all
that much more john is officially a
Dragon Rider and that's probably going
to be very important going forward the
hound and Arya that was an interesting
exchange they kind of played it tough
but I liked how Sandor gave a little
smile there when he said that's why
you're still alive it's subtle but you
know there is affection there and that's
the way that they would show that I
guess based on what we know about them
the gantry reunion was a little more
flirtatious which was surprising to me
in a way but it does make sense
it's full of callbacks which is always
fun and she wants to get this weapon
made and that's why she's there I like
how the drawing says the word
dragonglass on there with an arrow
pointing to the thing so that when we
zoom in we can see that that is a
special weapon for the battle upcoming I
really didn't see there being a romance
between these two but I don't know how
you could say that there's not something
hinted at here I guess it's okay aria
just doesn't seem like the type to
settle down but there's no problem with
flirting and you know having that part
of her character come out honestly I
didn't know if it would really exist
anymore so at least we know it's still
there we get an indication that not
everyone's on board with fighting
alongside Daenerys Deepwood Motte is not
answering the call Lord
staying home after getting that all the
way we get to the scene where Daenerys
goes to thank Sam for curing Jorah of
his greyscale and it turns out to be one
of the most emotional scenes of the
episode Sam starts out being kind of
confident and really taking to Daenerys
I always thought that this was something
that got a little bit too much play her
killing Randall and dick and Tarly in
the last season but here in Sam talk
about it damn you know what I mean like
maybe people were right when they said
that was unnecessarily cruel and kind of
concerning to me when I saw it at the
time I was like this is war that's the
kind of stuff that happens Dickon was
dumb for following his father into that
but she's in front of a bunch of people
and how she gonna back down in that
situation but yeah I thought John
Bradley did a great job here and it
really was one of my favorite parts of
the episode I think we kind of see in
Daenerys his face here how she struggles
she wants to be compassionate but at the
same time she can't change what she did
so I think her reaction to Sam was
pretty spot-on and that she's the queen
here this is an interaction between the
Queen and someone not to regular people
just having a chat doesn't make it any
easier for Sam and it doesn't make it
any easier for us as viewers to watch
him have to deal with this then we see
him go outside and he runs into bran who
says he's waiting for an old friend
and then he drops it on Sam that he has
to go tell Jon right now basically that
Ned isn't his father of course this
leads us into the big reveal as Sam goes
and finds John in the crypts it happened
kind of fast for me in that I wasn't
expecting Sam to be so forceful in the
way he delivered this because he just
heard about his brother and his father
that played a big part in it so yeah it
was interesting the first time I watched
I was like John didn't even really bring
up the idea that he's dating his aunt
but I kind of see how they went with it
as far as you know Ned was the most
honorable man he ever knew that's the
guy he looked up to all his life I read
the interview with kid Harrington when
he was talking about it he said that you
know Sam is nothing tomb in that moment
because this is so much of a shake to
his foundation telling him that Ned had
lied John says that you know he would
beat Sam up and disown him forever if he
found out that he was playing with him
on this level like if he was playing
with his emotions about something this
important the way what's important here
is Sam delivered the information perhaps
later on John will be like oh yeah I did
write a dragon maybe that's why but I
don't think there's any doubt left in
John by the time this wraps up and I
think that was what was important as far
as what had to happen he's gonna have a
period of time where he adjusts to the
idea he's gonna have to figure out what
it all means and he's gonna have to talk
to his partner here Daenerys and figure
out how that all shakes out starting
from Daenerys is revealed to Sam it's a
turn in the episode to where things get
pretty grave Don has to struggle with
this then we go up north a bit into the
last hearth and we see what happened to
Ned umber when I thought about this
episode beforehand and how everything
was pretty laid out I imagine there had
to be something to remind us of the
threat of course most of us who pay so
much attention we don't need a reminder
but you know casual fans might not be
sitting around at night charting where
they think the night Kings going or what
he wants and things like that so this
was our reminder that something's going
on and it's all headed towards
Winterfell it was kind of shocking the
symbolism was pretty strong as far as
using that swirl again
my head Canon on this for a long time
has been that ever since we saw the
children of the forest create the night
king in that location that swirl is
repeated in a lot of different things
that we see so my head cannons kind of
evolved to the thing of like this is
something that they know this is
something that is kind of a universal
symbol of where he came from it's a
reminder in a way of what they are a lot
of people pointed out the fact that it
looked like the Targaryen sigil kinda
when it was on fire and it did but I
don't know if that's what we were
supposed to take away from that at all
but either way there was a bit of horror
there berrak just says it right out this
is a message from the knight
like he knows what's going on it seemed
a little bit weird to me at the time but
yeah that's it works fine I guess then
we head back to Winterfell and we see
Jamie arrive and we see him spot bran
and we made the connection that bran has
been sitting there for a whole day more
or less like through the night into the
next day waiting for Jamie to arrive I'm
not a hundred percent convinced that
that's who he was waiting for but either
way we get this reunion which was the
one I was most interested to see
honestly and it's a pretty well acted
seeing there we see that there's
recognition from bran that hey there's
Jamie Lannister and we see Jamie sort of
shuffle through emotions in his head
before he arrives on the last bit of
like oh man you know this guy probably
wants revenge against me at least that's
what the actor described it as and I
think it came off pretty well the
question of whether bran is there
waiting for him or for someone else is a
natural question to ask I think if he is
waiting for Jamie then why would he be
specifically waiting for him if he's not
waiting for Jamie then who would he be
waiting for and that is where the
episode ends episode 1 of season 8 ends
the same way as episode 1 of season 1
does an interaction between Jamie and
bran and a fade to black so yeah I think
that you know there are some interesting
things here there was also a lot of
pushing stories along to get things to
where they needed to be I didn't love
the episode but I didn't hate it there
were things I loved in it and there were
things that I kind of hated in it I do
however accept it in order to have
payoffs later we have to have setups now
I think things are gonna get dark real
quick so I think it's okay to have a
little bit of fun with things for them
in the beginning some of the things I
found promising I liked that we saw a
little bit of humanity under the surface
of Arya and bran I think bran is gonna
play a really big part in preparing for
the battle and I think that he has a
unique role I mean obviously Jon and
Daenerys have their roles but I think he
has a unique role and actually defeating
the night king so I find it really
interesting to see who he's waiting for
and why
he's waiting for them I think he is
going to end up having a plan I do tend
to believe that that's who the night
king is after when he says he has a
target so I think bran would be able to
use that to his advantage and possibly
set a trap or do something to even
things up because the night King has a
huge advantage here it was a quick look
at Tyrion that was interesting that bran
made - I thought Tyrion had kind of a
weird episode I didn't think that he
really fit anywhere with any people I
mean he obviously was comfortable with
Varys and Davos talking about a marriage
proposal but I thought it was
interesting that we opened with him in
Varys but then we really didn't see them
playing a big effective role in anything
going on as far as the South is
concerned I think that it's pretty clear
that Cersei has lost her pregnancy most
of us expected that to happen it was
mentioned in the leaks that turned out
to be pretty accurate for Season seven
that there would be a scene where she
lost the child we never saw that
on-screen but it's also foreshadowed
there that Euron will not necessarily go
down with her if it turns out to be a
situation where they're gonna lose for
sure he says a tiara if he's fighting
for the wrong side then he'll take his
iron fleet and go somewhere else the
bran stuff is interesting but I'm not
sure how it figures into the endgame at
this point at least not what's in front
of them right now there's quite a lot of
foreshadowing I expect that since they
cut off John's talk with Sam about his
parentage and they cut off the reunion
between bran and Jaime that will pick
right up with those things and figure
out what's going on there I don't think
they'll leave those hanging I think
Jon's gonna have to reckon with that and
there's going to be a lot of other stuff
going on so there's going to be a lot of
tension leading up to the preparation I
expected that Tyrion would play a bigger
role but now he looks like he's kind of
being isolated in a way that's probably
foreshadowing about how things are gonna
go for him if bran was waiting for Jaime
then that's foreshadowing that he has
some big part to play in the battle for
Winterfell the ritualistic display of
Ned umbers body in the way this thing
went up in flames really kind of him
at what the night king is up to what he
wants and that would really take a lot
more explaining from my point of view so
I'll leave that there at this point I'm
certainly interested to see how things
will play out next time I made a trailer
breakdown for the second episode which I
think is going to be the preparation
episode because we know episode 3 is
going to be the Battle episode so you
can check that out there are several
different little bonus videos I'd like
to make related to this it's just gonna
be a question of whether I have the time
to do that this week or not so please
check back please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon
you